الاجسام الطائره المجهوله الهويه تهديد
غامض جديد استيقظت عليه الولايات المتحده
وعليها تحديد ماهيتها ومن ارسلها ومده
بقاء هذه الاجسام في الاجواء الامريكيه
تقول هنا تايمز البريطانيه اجهزه
المخابرات الامريكيه برمتها متاهبه لدراسه
الصور التي تم التقاطها في الساعات التي
سبقت اسقاط الطائرات المقاتله للاجسام
الثلاث الغامضه التي حلقت بالمجال الجوي
لامريكا الشماليه حتى الان مشاهدينا يبدو
انه لا توجد استنتاجات نهائيه والحقيقه
الوحيده الواضحه هي ان الاجسام الثلاثه لم
تكن مثل بالون التجسس الصيني هي اصغر
بكثير اي بحجم سياره صغيره كما نشاهد هنا
كما وصفها طبعا ايضا البنتاجون حيث تراوح
ارتفاع التحليق في اجواء الولايات المتحده
بين 20 و40 الف قدم احد الاجزاء او
الاجسام الطائره كان اسطوانيه الشكل وهو
عباره عن بالون معدني صغير يحمل شحنه
صغيره معلقه فيه وتم اسقاطه بالقرب من
مواقع امريكيه حساسه بحسب السلطات
الامريكيه وتحديدا في ولايه ميشيغان اما
الثالث فكان على شكل اوكتاجون ايسوماني
الزوايا والاضلاع ولديه خطوط مفصله ومتصله
ببعضها البعض كما نشاهد هنا ولكن الجسم
الثاني لم يحدد كيف كان شكله والجدير ذكره
هنا ان البنتاجون لم يستبعد ان تكون هذه
الاجسام قادمه من خارج كوكب الارض ولكن
البيت الابيض شدد على ان واشنطن لم تسجل
اي مؤشرات على نشاط مخلوقات فضائيه في
حوادث الاجسام الطائره المجهوله الهويه في
الاجواء الامريكيه الاستخبارات الامريكيه
كانت كاشفت في وقت سابق عن اكثر من 500
بلاغ تم
وتم تابع لاجسام طائره مجهوله في اجواء
البلاد تم اكتشافها من خلال الشيفات قديمه
تعود الى فتره امتدت الى 20 سنه بدورها
وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ناسا كشفت العام
الماضي انها اختارت سته عشر شخصا للمشاركه
في الدراسه التي طال انتظارها حول الظواهر
الجويه غير المحدده والتي يشار اليها
مشاهدينا باسم الاجسام الطائره المجهوله
ولا جواب طبعا حتى الساعه
[موسيقى]